you hear me all right at the back thank
you
so thanks for having me today this is my
very first talk at PI theta and also my
first event at a party fun event so this
is a really good opportunity for me to
talk about hto AI I just joined this
company about six weeks ago so the first
thing they asked me to do is you submit
an F track for this conference and then
thank you for tamale so give me this
opportunity so what I wanted to talk
about today is a specific features in
h2o this is only an introduction
materials for for this feature so don't
worry about it if you haven't seen or
heard about h2o before this is the
motivations or more about the story of
why we have to use these features to
save some time so let me give you a bit
of background myself so I work for h2o
as a customer data scientist so I help
our customer to use the data to help
them understand the data to peel some
smart app for them so before that I work
in a telecom industry I work for Virgin
Media so this is something similar to do
for a CEO and CFO we try to build some
small apt to answer some business
questions and at the same time I also
work part-time for another data science
platform called Domino data lab in the
US and what Charlie do for them is to
pull the product
can you hear me okay it's back so what
I'm trying to do for them is to do
rocket just call again
okay and and go to conference like this
to promote their product and well before
my Medina sense job I was a civil
engineer focusing in machine learning
and water engineering so I was more like
a engineer eternity the scientist so
this is a bit of information about h2o
we are a team of 50 we're going rapidly
so you can see 45 as in this photo and
terminer was found in 2012 in Mountain
View California it was backed by venture
capital fund so our main products about
an open source a machine learning
platform so we can use it in the web
interface cough Road you can also try
with the pipe one and out by we also
have API for Java and and as well so I'm
talking about a robot today so about
this talk I want to give you a story of
a baker and a data scientist so so what
what you care about the story of Baker
and data scientist this will give you a
bit of information of a background or
the motivations of why we would want to
use these functions in actually Oh to
optimize the hyper parameters and I will
talk about some common techniques that
we use to optimize this and I will show
you a quick demo of how we used actually
oh the Python API to do this
optimization
I'm also mentioning a bit of the other
features in each year that can help you
to streamline your data pipeline so
let's start with a story of a baker so a
bigger way they want to make a cake so
what do I do they have to do their to do
get some sauce which is ingredients in
this case eggs flour milk sugar
they have a process they have a
laborious process they have to mix it
they have to bake it and they have to
activate the end product is okay a
nice-looking cake that they can sell to
the customer and then look at let's look
at the story of the little scientist
it's actually quite similar so what we
have is some raw data we have to do some
data munging or we call it awakening we
have to do some analyze analysis and do
some modeling and at the end we won't
want to do want to we put the result in
some kind of visualizations or apps so
the end products the apps or some graphs
or maybe just a report so what do they
have in common in my experience the
process is quite important to us to the
baker to the data scientist but most of
the customer they do not care about the
process they do not appreciate your
effort you put into the process they
mostly care about the end product and
the quality of the materials so why do
you care about what you care about this
talk in the sense that because we should
focus on product a bit more than the
process we can use a machine or some
software to optimize some of the
laborious tasks for us in this case I
will show you how to use h2o to do this
if you can do that then we can spend
more time on the quality control Quality
Assurance and the presentation of the
product so this talk is mainly about
making one of the specific tasks the
hyper parameters optimizations or tuning
to be more efficient for you for your
data pipeline so let's give you an
overview of this process so what do we
think about optimizing our parameters is
that we what try to use that we try to
optimize and
be it a random forest with a gradient
booster machines the new network or
other algorithms we also optimize their
performance on some set of data we will
try to use different set of parameters
within an defined search space so we
test different combination of parameters
and see how they perform on the data but
there's no refunds that's not easy to
ponder so even if you are very
experienced can bring experience from
one dataset to another so it is a
difficult problem for some of the
machine learning petitioner to solve
without helping of the software so some
example of the parameters in h2o in some
of the algorithm you have for example
for the cheapest aqua from random
forests and gradient boosting machines
we want to optimize the number of cheese
depth of the trees and a sample weight
and for GBM you want may not want to do
it down the running wage and for deep
learning innumerable you may want to try
different activations try the different
size of eaten layers and you will try to
an l1 l2 like relations or drop always
there's so many things that you could
try in the algorithm but it's not easy
to straight away to point out what
setting is good for one model because
from one day I said to be the other the
other tail is always different so there
something is that we can use to
optimizes the the field terrains that we
have or what they have in h2o the first
one of course it's manual search so we
just fine-tune it yourself mainly so we
tune up one or two material per two
priorities at the same time and then you
observe the performance of the model on
theta this is always based on expedia
and it's not always reliable the other
way to look at it is to use a grid
search so you define a search base for
your parameters we just do a automatic
search through all the combinations of
those parameters this this would work
but at the same time you have that
there's a cause of the commutation power
so you may be having this panel of
components in no time on it a lot of cow
sauce curry sauce
and the third one is that we can
actually do it smartly so we do a random
grid search
so in this sense that we are still using
the same defined search space as a
manual search research but we're doing
random sampling point of a grid so this
has been proven to be have you know
equal performance in last time I didn't
say this because I did a empirical
experiments which is from paper that in
2012 so change Piscotty and Europe Benjy
know they did a research on America's
research on comparing research manual
search and random search and they found
that the binding research has eco
performance on comparing to the other
two so in that sense we think if it is
try and a charter state of some time
also won't talk about whatever features
in its forest shopping so this is
usually a tally for as Asians so we try
to avoid everything over the training
data set but it's quite useful we
combine this feature with about have
operators tuning because we can put in
additional controls in that feature so
we can set a time constraint set of
tokens on performance so we can maybe we
can save more time by stopping earlier
so so let's talk about how we do it in
actual so we wanted to carry out a
random search next door so we try to
optimize the model performance based on
a specific metric the area under curve
its accuracy with our tube or the
meeting square error of your choice so
this is based on order papal metrics
that we have implemented in hto then we
can define a search page for 4x 0 so we
want to say for this aqua form we want
search maybe numbers cheese may be the
sample which we give them basis start
with and then we use the early stopping
features for vocalizations and put in
more additional control so here is the
the only slide that we have -
coordinates so don't worry if you don't
if you're not familiar with the syntax
or the setting of this the main thing I
want to point out in here is that you
want to include two main arguments in
those in the in this case just the first
one is how we define the hyper pointers
for example this one is a we want to
search for two founders the first one is
the number of trees so we're saying that
okay actually I want you to look at
number of sheets from 10 50 and so on
and at the same time I want to do a
search on the Mac step for the cheese so
we start with 5 10 exactly so this is
the these are the search page that you
want to define in here
you can have more in for different
algorithm for this example we're just
want to look at two poetess the next
thing you want to look at is to define a
search criteria that some search
criteria for this research and you will
see that the first one we're saying that
the Sergey is random discrete if you
don't have this on it would do a turn or
mock research we will go through all the
search space but if you have this also
known we will try to use the default
argument to define a good strategy for
two random search so for example you can
set the maximum time for running so if
you don't have enough time to run the
full research you can say our one is one
for 600 seconds or you can set maximum
number of model you want to explore with
ten or five it depends on how much time
is like a trade-off between your
conversion no time and equus you want to
get to you can define your stopping much
here on the fourth line so Auto it being
the automatic choice for different
problems so if your problem is a
question problem they will define the
mean square order for your metric if
your problem is the last physical and
you define accuracy or area on the quest
for you you can do it multiple identify
on matrix in here
hello good and there are more arguments
in here use against us at currents for
stopping so if you want to see keep
improving the model for slight
improvement you can set us free number
for turbines and also you can see if we
stop improving four five one 10 months
you can stop that so these are the
parameters for race toppings and you can
also define a seat is a very important
for if you want to do the same thing
again so you'll keep you keep your
selection of random choices so after
that you put in this argument into extra
research so again don't worry about the
syntax here so I'll put all the code
examples on github so if you want to try
and they'll be a step before to show you
how to install how to load data in and
how to use this research for your model
this as a basic code to demonstrate how
you can put all these arguments together
so what we're saying here is that we
have a actual pitch search on a random
forest and then we put in the hyper
founders that we want to look at and we
put in the search criteria and after
this when we finish with the search you
can see the the best model the output of
that is the best model based on the
criteria based on the metric that you
defined and it was also we have the set
of the best have operators that lead to
the best model and on a kidnap we also
have talking documents for the other
ideas to do the same thing because our
we got a best and then we got Java we
all doing the same research so we can
see this document on github so there are
a few more features that make sure that
I couldn't talk about but I don't have
that could be literally another food on
top so I'll feature in cool extra
example which when you combine different
model different or maybe deep learning
model and random forest model and the
GBM together take if you buy the
pedigree performance on unseen data
you can also length extra webspot so we
call a sparkling water so which is like
painting the in-memory spark and it may
be make it show together to do the
machine learning bit so after all this
model you can also export the ping or
Java object pojo so this is good for
production eyes your your models when
you want to move it into a position a
moment so do ask me some questions about
this after the talk so I can point you
to other documents or have it install it
how to try with some example and so
let's go to the computer stop quickly I
think in my opinion most people only
care about the end product whether is
your your app yes my app your graphs
your reports in this case if you use
some machine learning algorithm or smart
choose to help you to save time on in
the process you may have more time to
actually think about the story to think
about how you can please sign your data
how you can check the quality of the
data it's good just to feel some time of
you to to better understand what the
customer require from your project
instead of spending lots of time on the
laborious tasks such as tuning the
performance of the models so X to the 1
amp research in the xeo is an efficient
way is to - in this and we can use this
for Python you can use it for our and
Java but but do check out the de Kock
example on github because this is more
like introduction Airy materials if you
want to look at the example and get up
and try it yourself please
look at the link on that's like and we
do have other features in a show that
can help you streamline the workflow and
so I will add fact go to different for
this opportunity today and a common
sponsor for this quake conference and I
also want to thank my colleague show
because I'm still calling to xgo
some some charities that I still have to
catch up with this but it's a it's been
a great journey for me to understand
what kind of polish they're making and
they try to democratize the restaurants
for everyone so this is open source
everyone can try it they can have email
me performance in from a memory machine
earnings open for everyone and if you
haven't tried before
please come to me and I can help you set
up your machines to hto on different
examples so these are the link for the
resource so Duke oh and down H so we
have a try and look at documentation if
you have some questions give me a yeah
and we're also hiring as well because we
want to expand the engineering
department and other department as well
so we want to bring in more algorithms
into H 2 O so please get in touch if
you're interested thank you
start from the back
so thanks for your talk I have a
question about the parameter search
using the random searching of the of the
parameter space have you is there also
functionality in h2o to do some kind of
guided search say so a would used the
difference in the results to do some
kind of backdrops to optimize to go
faster than just randomly that's
independence the Bayesian approach for
the next step so at the moment it's
still just a random quiz search for the
next day is to use different search
results as a base in evidence update to
update the base in research so that
would be the next stage but yes that
would be the next one okay next question
was thanks for your talk you mentioned
that there is no rules of thumb in the
parameter optimization but strictly
speaking so true for example for
gradient boosting trees you want to
optimize tree option first boosters
second and the learning rate as a last
option because if you just try to
optimize all options yeah advanced every
time you hit a small learning rate
you'll just get very very slow
performance and you can miss a point but
can you in your random function use
these heuristics to just get better
results because you know it's about 20
parameters in in gradient boosting trees
it's not possible to just do randomly
all all this 20 dimensional space yeah I
think this is a two-way learning problem
so at the same time we provide this
function in HDL and same time we try to
learn how to use that we use these
functions this feature to optimize it so
what we try to do to put in something
that is working in h2o first and then we
try to learn from the user behavior and
see how we can actually make it smarter
smarter by meaning that we can actually
go for like a pre set of parameters so
we are try to layout down the search
space for the users and put for
different problems
but we haven't been to that stage yet
there will be the next stage but for now
we put in this function so people can
give it a go and give them a try
I think if you do this again and again
for a few times you have some good idea
of where to start with but you you will
never be very sure of what's the best
way to to optimize the parameters so
this will give you some way to to
automate some of the part some part of
the jobs but not the perfect answer to
the end so what we're trying to do to
learn at the same time is to how to make
it even smarter then why not just a
random grid search but by using all the
information that we can get from a user
feedback so I encourage you to give it a
try and get some feedback and see how we
can improve it in the future next
question was
a very very interesting you mentioned
the article of death in Bengal they also
wrote a package a hyper art which serves
the same purpose how do these packages
compare yeah because this package in
extra this feature NetZero is focused on
the algorithm in hto so it's not
applicable to any other go from outside
to oh so we did that because we need
something functionable in XTO so we can
carry on to do ultimate station on h2o
and we haven't actually compared a
package to other because a package is
focus on mainly on actual algorithm but
what we're trying to do at the same time
is you will expand the list of algorithm
supported in H 2 O so we're trying to
bring in tensorflow from Google which
one open in other open source algorithm
from different places together into the
single single platform in actual and at
that time we may have more element to it
together then we can make a more Apple
to Apple direct conversions to other
package before
our questions if not the let's thank our
speakers Joe